so there is a lot going on on the uh
it's not even clear whether it's fair to
call it the left but the the true
extremist Fringe in this country
um and it's not all trans people of
course but the extremist trans Fringe
um is a lot more threatening than most
people understand any no has been
covering has been covering antifa uh for
years now he's the author of unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy he's a senior at a
post-millennial he joins us tonight Andy
thanks so much for coming on
um so again you don't want to get too
broad brush here but there is an
extremist movement obviously it's very
evident online in the aftermath of this
mass murder are you surprised to see it
no so in my reporting on antifa for
years now one
um observation that I noticed was that
disproportionately the number of Riot
arrestees uh are gender diverse and by
that I mean they don't identify with
their biological sex
um on some nights it was as high as 20
percent and that is magnitudes higher
than what the data we have on people in
the in the wider American population who
are trans identifying so you know I
looked into into this a bit further
there is some period reviewed research
out of Canada you can find it on the
Library of Medicine
that shows that there's evidence that
young transgender people particularly
vulnerable to violent radicalization and
in my reporting on left-wing extremism
in months for months now I've documented
and tracked this surge in violent
rhetoric by AI self-identified trans
militant activists particularly on
Twitter in response to various States
restricting or Banning the medical
transitioning of minors as you mentioned
earlier the horrific murder of children
and staff at the Christian school
yesterday does come just days ahead of a
so-called trans-day Vengeance that's
being organized in the U.S Capitol and
unfortunately myself and other people
who have reported on this and posted
this flyer which by the way that group
is still online if you posted the flyer
regardless of the context you're locked
out of your account so currently I
cannot access my Twitter
can I ask you just a quick macro
question so one of the reasons that so
many well-meaning middle-aged moms in
this country bought into support of the
trans Community is on the basis of the
promise that it's Liberation and this is
kids when they finally Express their
true inner identity will be happier and
better adjusted but the incidence of
violence and mental illness seems to be
extraordinary so it doesn't seem like
people are being liberated it seems like
people are being tormented and driven
driven to the brink of insanity that
just watching that seems clear
it's the exact opposite of Liberation we
have mountains of evidence that people
who suffer from gender dysphoria also
suffer from very high rates of
mental health comorbidities
when you have this reality on top of
people being fed cross-sex hormones and
are also being in an environment where
they are encouraged to have a violent
hatred a wider society and you can see
this in the reaction before during and
after this this killing
Andy now thank you for your incisive and
and very informed analysis of this
appreciate it subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight